the president of the united states has
had a tweet flagged by twitter because
it is encouraging people not to vote by
telling them things that are not true
about coronavirus this is incredible the
the sitting president of the united
states is violating the terms of service
of a social media platform not for
something unrelated to his election
but because he is spreading
disinformation about his
own upcoming re-election donald trump
tweeted quote
so now the democrats are using mail drop
boxes which are a voter security
disaster now of course
these are municipalities using the boxes
it's not democrats
trump goes on to say among other things
they make it possible for
for a person to vote multiple times also
who controls them
are they placed in republican or
democrat areas
they are not covid sanitized a big
fraud and rightly twitter put the
message up on the tweet which says
this tweet violated the twitter rules
about civic and election
integrity so there are really two parts
here
the first is donald trump is continuing
to say that vote by mail absentee drop
boxes
none of it is secure this is not true
trump is saying that without evidence
i'm sure you know that by now
part two of this is this new idea of
playing on people's fears of coronavirus
by saying
you know the drop boxes for the ballots
they're not
covered sanitized and this is a clear
attempt to dissuade biden voters
how do we know that because biden voters
we know
are taking coronavirus more seriously
than our trump voters
biden voters are more likely to be
planning to vote by mail
to avoid maybe catching coronavirus at a
polling place
biden voters are more likely to wear
masks when they go outside
so we know that if you start spreading
the idea
the ballot dropbox might give you the
virus
you were going to disproportionately hit
biden voters
but it could backfire if democrats
are more likely not to believe what
trump says
and trump voters are more likely to
believe what donald trump says
it's conceivable that this idea of
saying you know you could get
coronavirus from the dropbox
it might end up keeping his own voters
at home i
don't think in the end it will have a
hugely disproportionate
impact one way or the other but twitter
is completely correct to flag his tweet
and to put a warning on it donald trump
is terrified
that people are going to come out and
vote in huge numbers and not for him but
for the other guy
and in fact the entire republican party
is terrified of that i expect
that as the election gets closer trump
is going to be going even crazier and
pulling out all the stops
everything will be on the table we have
to make sure it backfires
we have to keep publicizing that he's
doing this because
there's one thing we know people will be
more determined to vote
the more they realize trump doesn't want
them to people are just like that by
nature
the post office was a turning point for
many americans
sending troops into cities was a turning
point for many americans
this is a cult it's a dangerous one and
a lot of people understandably would
crawl
over broken glass to vote in november
the president of the united states is
trying to suppress the vote
obviously he should have long ago been
banned from twitter
regularly bullying people breaking just
about every term and condition they have
but this is bigger than twitter mail-in
ballots are bad ballot drop boxes could
be infected with coronavirus
we have to stop it we have to stop it
and uh
you listen let's skip it you know what
you have to do
i'm really excited that one of our
sponsors today is
helix sleep i sleep on a helix mattress
at home
i absolutely love it and that's why i
reached out to them about sponsoring the
david pakman show
buying a mattress in the past was always
a huge guessing game for me
i didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like but
helix has a sleep quiz on their website
you tell them your body type your
sleeping position
your back pain issues you might have and
their tool
matched me with a mattress that is
perfect for me
it's cool enough at night it's the right
firmness
i generally just do way better sleeping
these days because of the mattress helix
was awarded
number one best overall mattress for the
last two years
by both gq and wired magazine it is well
deserved i can tell you firsthand
every helix mattress comes with a 10
year warranty
you can try the mattress risk free for
100 nights
and they will even come pick it up at
your house if you don't love it
but i know you will all of my viewers
will get up to
200 off your order and you'll get two
super premium pillows for free
when you go to the link right underneath
this video